you know I got to ask you something
because you know recently uh you know
you shut down a claim from Rolling Stone
that named Harry Styles the new king of
Pop I mean what was your take on that
and why is that a title that is only
reserved for your dad because there's so
many technological social factors that I
think went into the earning of the title
King of Pop and I don't see it as a
slight to anybody else's career because
they've had their own length of
achievements but the King of Pop is a
unique achievement because he broke
boundaries in countries that didn't have
the same infrastructure that they do now
he was popular on a global basis at one
point the most famous person in the
world and for all these reasons and his
music the King of Pop is a title that I
just don't think could ever be taken I
think that's totally fair but let me ask
you this is there one artist in pop
music today that you feel is like
clearly following in the footsteps of
your dad and who's getting close to that
you know who kind of emulates his talent
his dedication and all that made Michael
Jackson Michael Jackson personally like
the first person that comes to mind is
actually Beyonce right yes I think that
the way she approaches music and I don't
really I don't know her personally but
from what I've seen from a professional
standpoint and from I know my dad
idolized her as well when she was just
coming up so he kind of predicted that
if you will he saw that same fire and
dedication in her and for me I felt like
that she's she's she's up there
all right Prince so we're in the Legacy
room which is kind of a trip and I feel
like an idiot because I'm dressed in a
mock-up of the Thriller jacket this
ain't real okay you feel like an idiot
I'm dressed as Mario right now it's
Halloween right it is it is I mean let's
start there because it must be a trip
for you to know that every Halloween
people are dressed like your dad and
everybody is blasting Thriller yes yes
it's an honor when I hear Thriller
playing this time of year
talk to me about this Legacy room
because there are some I mean one of a
kind and original pieces here right so
what's in this room so this room
originally was in a ward room so when my
dad came back and he won all those
Awards he put them actually on display
in this room yeah and so we've taken
we've tried to pay homage to the history
of this room and that's why we've deemed
it the Legacy room and right now we have
one of the jackets from the music video
of Thriller right here
honestly we're out of gas and I know my
dad's signature is actually right here
yes just in case you didn't realize that
this is the OG this is the actual jacket
your dad's signature is right there so
it's not just Grammy's up here though
right no it's more than that but these
eight specifically were the ones that he
brought home that night
and I've never seen them all on display
like this so for me I'm gravitating
towards it just because that moment is
Iconic like I've seen it in photos I
wasn't around to experience it so to be
here amongst that history is just
mind-blowing be honest be honest Prince
have you ever tried to recreate that
photo have you grabbed all eight Grammys
before yet somebody told me that and I
can't I don't know how he held all of
them hey they're heavy and B if I drop
it oh I would never forgive myself I'll
never forget myself
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I'm having a little bit of a fanboy
moment right now because that's the
iconic glove right there I mean that's
insane right yes yes it is impressive
now it's not the Motown 25 glove I don't
believe okay but it is a touring glove
that he had with him on multiple
occasions your dad was shiny shimmering
splendid okay I love that it's in this
case right here and it's to the Fedora
that's you gotta have the Fedora and the
glove right all right so I recognize
this too right here but tell the folks
what what this look is from so this if
you've ever seen the album of Thriller
with the tiger cub on his knee this is
that suit right here come on look how
fresh it still is it's so fresh and
you're I gotta tell your dad was spell
all right yeah I feel like I could fit
in that Prince not that I'm gonna try
and put it on I won't do that I won't do
that
[Music]
obviously we're celebrating 40 Years of
your dad's iconic album what does this
record mean to you I mean how often do
you go back to it and listen to it every
October and honestly anytime I'm on the
motorcycle it comes up in my random
playlist it's just it makes me feel so
proud to have a history and a Heritage
and proud of what my dad accomplished
over the years because we're here 40
years later and it's nuts it must mean a
lot to know that this episode resonates
with so many people and it has stood the
test of time right what does it mean to
know that like your dad's Legacy really
lives on through this catalog it means
everything it means everything I
remember uh when we were celebrating the
25th anniversary of Thriller we were
watching the uh the flash mobs the
prisoners I don't know if you remember
when they were all doing the Thriller
dance
so that was a really cool way to be
celebrating the 25th and now to be there
you know I'm not going to even do the
math but here we are at the 40th right
and to be celebrating it and to see so
much love and so much respect from my
father still to this day is incredible I
gotta know have you learned the
choreography yet have you ever taken a
stab at it to try and do the whole dance
break I have not I know because if I am
gonna do it I'm gonna have to take like
three months maybe to learn it and I'm
gonna bust it out when nobody's
expecting it
hahaha
[Music]